Раптові проблеми зі здоров'ям часто виникають в опонентів російської влади.
Останній випадок із підозрою на навмисне отруєння стався з Петром Верзіловим,
якого чартерним рейсом терміново доправили з Москви до Берліна -
у головну клініку німецької столиці.
Клінічна картина, яку ми зараз спостерігаємо,
з високою вірогідністю свідчить, що сталося отруєння.
В нас немає жодних підстав вважати, що теперішній стан пацієнта можна пояснити якось інакше.
Петро Верзілов, чиє ім'я пов’язане з панк-групами "Війна" та "Pussy Riot",
влаштовує політичні перформанси з критикою режиму в Росії вже понад десять років.
Під час останньої акції він на очах мільйонів людей
вибіг на футбольне поле у Москві під час фіналу Чемпіонату світу з футболу -
серед глядачів був і російський президент Путін.
11 вересня Верзілову несподівано стало зле після того, як він побував у московському суді.
Його подруга Вероніка Нікульшина викликала швидку.
Йому ставало дедалі гірше.
Він почав втрачати координацію рухів, не міг йти, не міг говорити, став дезорієнтованим,
не міг контролювати себе і взагалі не розумів, що з ним відбувається.
Надія Толоконникова вважає, що його отруєння стало реакцією
на зростання політичної активності в Росії - передусім серед молоді.
Молодь виходить на вулиці міст, каже про те, що ми більше не хочемо миритися з Володимиром Путіним,
що ми хочемо іншої країни, просто хочемо адекватної влади,
яка буде нас чути, ми хочемо будувати іншу країну,
в якій ми зможемо комфортно жити при тому, що ми інші.
Лікарі поки не можуть прогнозувати, як довго Верзілов лежатиме в берлінському стаціонарі.
Офіційний Берлін заявляє, що стежить за ситуацією.
Ймовірно, розслідування того, що сталося, порушить Канада:
Петро Верзілов має подвійне - російсько-канадське громадянство.